what I want to do in this video is give
a very high-level overview of the four
fundamental forces four fundamental
forces of the universe and I'm going to
start with gravity I'm going to start
with gravity and it might surprise some
of you that gravity is actually the
weakest of the four fundamental forces
that's surprising because you say wow
that's what keeps us glued not glued but
it keeps us from jumping off the planet
it's what keeps the moon in orbit around
the earth the earth in orbit around the
Sun the Sun in orbit around the the
center of the Milky Way galaxy so it's
it's a little bit surprising that it's
actually the weakest of the forces and
and that starts to make sense when you
actually think about things on maybe
more of a human scale or a molecular
scale or even an atomic scale even on a
human scale your computer monitor and
you have some type of gravitational
attraction but you don't notice it or
your cell phone and your wallet there's
gravitational attraction but you don't
see them being drawn to each other the
way you might see two magnets drawn to
each other or repelled from each other
and if you've got even a smaller scale
you'll see that it matters even less we
never even talk about gravity and
chemistry although the gravity is there
but at those scales the other forces
really really really start to dominate
so gravity's are weakest so if we move
up a little bit from that we get and
this is maybe the the hardest force for
us to visualize or at least the hardest
the least intuitive force for me is
actually the weak force the weak
sometimes called the weak interaction
and it's what's responsible for
radioactive decay in particular beta
minus and beta plus decay and just to
give you an example of the actual weak
interaction if I had some cesium 137 137
means it has 137 nucleons a nucleon is
either a proton or a neutron you add up
the protons and neutrons of cesium you
get 137 and it is cesium because it has
exactly 55 protons now the weak
interaction is what's responsible for
one of the neutrons
essentially one of its corks flipping
and turning into a proton and I'm not
going to go into detail of what a cork
is and all of that and the math can get
pretty hairy but I just want to give you
an example of what the weak interaction
does so if one of these one of these
neutrons turns into a proton then we're
going to have one extra proton but we
have the same number of nucleons instead
of a extra Neutron here you now have an
extra proton here and so now this is a
different atom it is now barium and in
that flipping it will actually emit
it'll actually emit an electron and an
anti-electron neutrino and I'm not going
to go into the details of what an
anti-electron neutrino is these are
fundamental particles but this is just
what that weak interaction is it's not
something that's completely obvious to
us it's not kind of this traditional
things pulling or pushing away from each
other like we would like we associate
with the other the other forces now the
next strongest force and just to give a
sense of how weak gravity is even
relative to the weak interaction the
weak interaction is 10 to the 25th times
the strength of gravity times the
strength of gravity and you might
anything if this is so strong how come
this doesn't operate on planets or us
relative to the earth or the reason you
know why doesn't this apply to
intergalactic distances the way gravity
does and the reason is the weak
interaction really applies to very small
distances very very small distances so
it can be much stronger than gravity but
only over very very and it really only
applies on the sub atomic scale you go
anything beyond that it kind of
disappears as an actual force as an
actual interaction now the next the next
force up the hierarchy which is one that
we are more familiar with it is
something it's what actually dominates
most of the chemistry that we deal with
and electromagnetism that we deal with
and that's the electro magnetic force we
write it in magenta electro
magnetic magnetic force and just to give
a sense this is this is 10 to the 36
times the strength of gravity 10 to 36
times the strength of gravity so it kind
of puts the weak force in its place it's
10 to the 12 times stronger than the
weak force so these are huge numbers
that we're talking about either this
relative that or even this relative to
gravity and so you might be saying well
you know the electromagnetic force
that's unbelievably strong why doesn't
that apply over over over these these
kind of macro scales like gravity let me
write there macro scales macro scales
why doesn't it apply to macro scales and
actually there's nothing about the
electromagnetic force why it can't it or
it actually does apply over large
distances the reality though is you
don't have these huge concentrations of
either electric Ullom charges or
magnetism the way you do mass so the
mass that you have such huge
concentrations it can operate over huge
huge distances even though it's way way
way weaker than the electromagnetic
force the electromagnetic force what
happens is because it's both attractive
and repulsive it tends to kind of sort
itself out so you don't have these huge
huge huge concentrations of charge now
the other thing you might be wondering
about is you know why is it called the
electromagnetic force in our everyday
life there's things like there's things
like the Coulomb force that or the
electrostatic force which we're familiar
with positive charges or like charges
want to repel if both of these were
negative the same thing would be
happening and different charges like to
attract we've seen this multiple times
this is the Coulomb force or the
electrostatic force electro static and
then on the other side of the word yes
you have the magnetic part and magnets
you know you have you've played with
magnets on your fridge they what's what
you know if they're the same side of the
magnet they're going to repel each other
if they're the opposite sides opposite
poles they're going to attract each
other so why is it called one force and
it's called one force and once again I'm
not going to go into detail here it's
called one force because it turns out
that the cool
force the electrostatic force and the
magnetic force are actually the same
thing viewed in different frames of
references so I won't go into a lot of
detail but just keep that in the back of
your mind that they are connected in a
future video I'll go more into the
intuition of how they are connected and
it deals with when what it's more
apparent when they're moving when the
charges are moving at relativistic
frames and you have well I will go to a
lot of detail there but just keep in
mind that they really are the same force
just viewed from different frames of
reference now the strongest of the force
is probably the best name of them all
and that's the strong force that is the
strong force the strong force and
although you probably haven't seen this
yet in our in chemistry classes it
actually applies very strongly in
chemistry because from the get-go when
you first learn when you first learn
about atoms let me draw a helium atom a
helium atom has two protons and it's
nucleus two protons in its nucleus and
it has two neutrons and then it also has
two electrons circulating around so it
has an electron and I can draw the
electrons is much smaller than well I
won't I won't try to do anything in
relative size but it has two electrons
floating around and one question that
may or may not have jumped into your
mind when you first saw this model of an
atom is like well I see why the
electrons are attracted to the nucleus
it has a negative Coulomb charge the
nucleus has a net positive Coulomb
charge but what's not so obvious and
that what tends not to sometimes be
explained in chemistry class is these
two positive charges are sitting right
next to each other if the
electromagnetic force was the only force
in play if the Coulomb force was the
only thing happening these guys would
just run away from each other they would
repel each other and so the only reason
why they're able to stick to each other
is that there's an even stronger force
than the electromagnetic force operating
at these very very very small distances
so if you get two of these protons close
enough together and the strong force
only applies over very very very small
distances subatomic I should even say
sub nucleic distances then
the strong interaction comes into play
so then you have the strong interaction
actually keeping these charges together
and once again just to keep it in in in
mind relative to gravity it is 10 to the
38th 10 38 times the strength times the
strength of gravity or it's about a
hundred times stronger than the
electromagnetic force so once again the
reason why you don't see the strong
force which is the strongest of all of
the forces or the weak interaction
applying over huge scales is that they
really only they only their strength
dies off super super fast even when you
start going to large radius nucleuses of
atoms they strength starts to die off
especially for the strong force the
reason why you don't see the
electromagnetic force operating over
large distances even though in theory it
can like gravity is that you don't see
the type of charge concentrations the
way you see mass concentrations in the
universe because the charge
concentrations tend to sort them out
they start to equalize if I have if I
have some if I have some positive a huge
positive charge there and a huge
negative charge there they will attract
each other and then become essentially a
big lump of neutral charge and once
they're a big lump of neutral charge
they won't they won't interact with
anything else in gravity if you have one
mass and another mass and they attract
each other then you have another mass
that's even better to attracting each
other at other masses and so it'll keep
attracting things to it so it kind of
snowballs the process and that's why
gravity can operates on these really
really large large objects in our
universe in the universe as a whole